تخفي هذه الساعه الجديده بعض الحيل
التقنيه البارعه فهي مقاومه للماء وللحقل
المغناطيسي والصدمات انها ساعه مستوحاه من
اكثر الساعات مبيعا في السبعينيات للعلامه
التجاريه انجينير
والتي لا يزال هواه ساعات يشترونها تعرض
لاول مره في معرض الساعات والعجائب 2022
احد اكبر معارض الساعه في العالم في جنيف
معرض الساعات والعجائب اكثر من مجرد حدث
انه قمه صناعه الساعات تجمع الصناعه
باكملها فهي تتيح للزوار مقابله المؤثرين
في عالم صناعه الساعات
اشهر صانع الساعات الفاخره حاضرون في
المعرض بما في ذلك شوباغ السويسريه حدثت
هذه العلامه التجاريه هدفا باستخدام 80%
من الفولاذ المعادي تدويره في صناعه
ساعتها بحلول نهايه العام الجاري
لا نستخدم الى الفولاذ الذي اعيد تدويره
بنسبه تصل الى 80% وما زلنا نقدم معايير
عاليه الجوده وبما اننا نقوم بتخفيض ما
بين 25 طنا من الفولاذ كل عام فهذه ليست
كميه ضئيله وبالتالي فاننا نساهم في
التقليل من انبعاثات الكربون بنحو 30% في
حالتنا
تتناقض واجهات العرض البراقه والساعات
باهظه الثمن بشكل حاد مع ازمه تكلفه
المعيشه التي تؤثر على معظم انحاء العالم
بين ان اهل الصناعه هنا يتحدثون عن ارتفاع
الطلب على الساعات السويسريه الفاخره
وتسجيل صادراتها ارقاما قياسيه
من المثير للدهشه ان صناعه الساعات حققت
اداء جيده للغايه ربما لان الناس ما زالوا
يريدون ان يكونوا قادرين على الابتهاج او
الاستمتاع ببعض الفرح في حياتهم او
بالتاكيد يعتبر البعض الساعه ايضا
استثمارا
وفقا لاتحاد صناعه ساعات السويسريه زادت
صادرات الساعات السويسريه باكثر من 11%
العام الماضي
مقارنه في عام 2021 لتصل الى ما يقرب من
سبعه وعشرين مليار دولار
واحده من اغلى الساعات في المعرض هي باتيك
فيليب بسعر يفوق اربعه ملايين دولار فقط